hi there steve goffin here today today i
want to talk about something that's very
important in language learning i'm going
to show you
again on my computer how i find
interesting content to learn from and
appropriate content
to learn from when i'm learning a
language
finding
what stephen krashen refers to as
meaningful content is essential to
success essential to achieving fluency
it's not by learning grammar rules that
you're going to learn to speak well
in fact there's a strong argument that
the more you focus on grammar rules the
more you start
thinking through rules is this correct
this is not correct you move away from a
natural control of the language to one
where you're constantly second guessing
yourself now in my last video i showed
you how i save phrases and tag them so
it's a good thing to be conscious of
different structures in the language
part of that can be and needs to be some
knowledge
of the grammar so you every so often
need to refer to the grammar i believe
and i'm perhaps moving away from krashen
but the goal there is to make you more
uh
aware to notice better certain things in
the language the goal of grammar
instruction is not to try to memorize
rules because then you find yourself
it's like the centipede who doesn't know
which
leg
to start walking with these things have
to eventually become natural and they
become natural through lots of exposure
listening and reading
to content that is of interest and yet
at your level
there is an expression experience is the
great teacher
uh content is where you gain your
experience with the language
the content is the great teacher when it
comes to language learning you can
enhance
the effectiveness
of this teaching by
training yourself to notice things
but that's not the same as
memorizing uh declension tables
conjugation tables and rules i don't
believe in memorizing and trying to use
these rules when you're speaking instead
i think and what i try to do is expose
myself to so much content and while
exposing myself i try to this content
through massive listening and reading
listening and reading to interesting
stuff i try to pay attention to certain
things which might be pronunciation
which might be certain structures which
might be certain bits of vocabulary and
i picked them up here and there and by
noticing these things i gradually become
familiar enough with the language that
my comprehension improves my vocabulary
increases and eventually my ability to
speak
develops so
i want you again to look over my
shoulder as i get onto the link and i
look for
content interesting meaningful content
so let's go there right now
all right so here we are we're at my
lesson page we're going to look at
how we find suitable content
i've chosen italian because although i'm
not studying italian i have dabbled in
it a little bit over the last little
while
but it might be easier for people to
follow than ukrainian or greek which are
the languages that i spend most of my
time
learning so the first thing we notice
here
on the lesson page
is that there are four boxes up here
these are the four courses that i was
last using or learning from
so let's talk about
the difference between lesson and course
a lesson at link is simply
content remember that content the
language itself is the teacher
so
content interesting meaningful content
is what teaches us the language so it's
very important that we find content
that's at our level
a little difficult
and interesting
that's a lesson now lessons are grouped
in courses a course is simply a
collection of lessons it could be a
an author that has been put in all of
whose articles have been put into a
collection it could be this series of
many stories we have which are
simpler and for people at a lower level
in the language
it could be uh play
uh it could be anything
it's simply where people who have
uploaded lessons
to our linked library have grouped them
into collections which we call courses
these four boxes show me the last four
places where i was
so for example in the link mini story
series the last mini story
i looked at was lesson one all right
now we look at what we call the lesson
feed the lesson feed is where we can
easily access content to learn from
i have and it shows what other people
have been learning for example three
hours ago this user studied this which
was a conversation between sabina and
michaela
four years ago this learner studied
this uh discussion between danilo and
rita about toscana
also you will find in the feed
articles from newspapers which
automatically show up here if you choose
to import them you can learn you can
either use articles from gazetta de la
sport or rai news or whatever and so on
down the line this is offered to you as
suggestions you can also
change the level here so that depending
on where you are you may not want
advanced to
uh
you may only advance one advancement so
you can decide just what range of
lessons you want to be looking at
all right
the
lesson library
is a place where you can search for
articles and you can search by different
terms let's say you could search for you
wanted to hear about
let's say you can even search in english
so economics
economics let's see what comes up
and because these lessons are tagged you
should get uh
audio and text
lessons
uh a variety of them that you can choose
to open
uh
now this all seems to come from well
robin good is uh
despite the name is an italian um
podcast
but you can also uh if you were like
looking for articles about florence you
can type in firenze and see what comes
up
all right so
this is how you can search the library
my lessons is simply convenient place to
look at the last are lessons rather than
you know courses the last lessons that
you've been studying
so that's how you deal with the very
very very large content
uh collection that is to be found in our
library at link lots of interesting
material always with audio and text
remember the content is the teacher
now if we go if we are not happy with
what we find there we can also import
there's two ways of importing one way is
to click on the import lesson button
and here you can
import a lesson so you go to some place
including
ebooks
and you
copy and paste the lesson into here put
the title up here
uh
you can
choose
the
course that you wanted to be under or
you can add a new course if you're
bringing in a an ebook for example you
would put you would click that and
put in the title of the new course that
you've created
if you are going to share this right now
it's private you can import unlimited
stuff privately and there are no
restrictions but if you are going to
share it in our library you have to
upload an audio file with it you also
have to make sure that this is not
protected under copyright when you've
done all of that you click save
and it's saved or save and open and you
can start studying it that's one way
another way
is if you have for example and we'll go
here this is a an article from corriere
de la sera
you can easily find italian newspapers
online and if you go over to this icon
and click on it
then this opens up and this is now going
to be
imported you have to choose
i will call this portiere de la sera
and you click on import and it imports
so that's another way of importing
lessons
now while we're on the subject of
bringing lessons in
when i study once i get past the simple
content
and i very much recommend
very much recommend
the uh these mini stories as a great
place to start in a language
and a place that you go back to over and
over again to work on the basic
structures and the basic vocabulary in
the language i have done this in greek i
have done it in in slovak
it's very effective however at a certain
point you want to deal with
uh scholar call it authentic content so
i mentioned you could import uh material
from newspapers
uh you can also bring in
ebooks
so i have
done this for polish for czech for
russian for ukrainian in this case in
italian what you do you go to google
translate and if you're unsure
about how to say ebook
uh you just
italian
oh ebook that's pretty good if you're
looking for ukrainian you would see
another so use google translate to help
you find a search term which enables you
to find these great sites where you can
buy ebooks or
some of them are free and there's just
an unlimited
availability of these
in order to import these books into link
i suggest you get a piece of software
called caliber so that you can convert
any ebook into material that can be used
at link when it comes to audio for
italian i hardly recommend il naratore
audio libri because they have audio
books and they also have audio books
combined with
ebooks so that's a great place to find
material to bring into link if you are
in other languages a site that i
recommend is audio techa
because here this happens to be english
but they offer
uh
you know
audio books
in a variety of languages
so that it's a great source of material
and i'm only scratching the surface
there are lots of places to find
interesting content to learn from so
this is just a start to this whole issue
of content
uh i very i would look forward to
hearing from you uh if you have
questions about
finding good content
or
if you have questions about other
aspects of how to use link i'm going to
continue this series on how to use link
and i look forward to your questions and
comments
thank you for listening and remember if
you enjoy
my youtube channel please subscribe
[Music]
you